[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Marcellus Wiley the former NFL All-Pro
defensive end host of more to it podcast
on The Dan Patrick Podcast Network and
he joins us now is that a must-like
situation there Marcellus that do you
think Jalen hurts is going to play
against Cowboys no I don't think he's
going to play against the Cowboys and he
doesn't think so as well but he
understands his role and he understands
it fully as the leader of this team uh
Jalen hurts Beyond his talent his
character is what's really driving this
team to make him accountable and while
they're on this win streak right now and
have the number one seed and Jalen hurts
knows he doesn't want to drop the ball
in terms of the momentum this team has
right now saying that you're going to
just pass the Baton The Gardener men's
shoe without a fight make some people
question you in the locker room that's
the football culture you have to Die
Trying so Jalen hurts knows even if he's
physically not able to go out there
verbally he has to act like he can okay
what would you do if like if he's iffy
to be able to play
like how well how important is this game
for the Eagles we know how important it
is for the Cowboys
yeah you know it's interesting there's
always layers to it like right now
you're talking to your audience but then
during commercial break you talk to the
dentist and you guys say different
things obviously you're privy to
different information if you're on the
inside so on the inside as a teammate I
would know the real I would see them in
the training room I'll say what's up you
good I don't know dog I don't know dog
has a no in it it doesn't have I don't
yes dog I don't know dog so we get it
and then you have to go out there and
publicly profess something so that we
can still hold some hope out but at the
same time when I've been in that
predicament before I've kept it real on
the inside and fake on the outside
trying to figure out Dak Prescott of it
always feels like when we say oh where
is the top 10 quarterback
he's around 10.
why isn't he higher or what what's
missing for him to move up the
quarterback ladder in your opinion
uh one the scrutiny is so intense that
we're going to question ourselves even
when we believe what we see with our
eyes that's what happens when you wear
the star on your helmet Dak Prescott
suffers from that also Dak Prescott has
had a ton of resources but not all of
them at the same time let's just
remember this when he had the offensive
line that was young and balling and
Ezekiel Elliott was bawling when he was
young he didn't have a defense then all
of a sudden you start to see some of the
holes in Ezekiel Elliott offensive line
then you start seeing flashes from the
defense then all of a sudden you look up
and he doesn't have the receiving core
he needs but he has the defense and the
running game could be there if they
committed to Pollard fully but they're
going back and forth trying to respect
the contract Ezekiel Elliott I look at
this like it's Dallas so we're always
going to find something critical to say
Dak Prescott is certainly a great
quarterback but how great is always
going to suffer because of where his
location and more importantly everything
that he has he's not had at the same
time so I think that's why he hovers
around number 10. is there a quarterback
who's under more pressure
I can't name him I don't see anybody
else and the pressure is because people
won't give you your flowers the pressure
is when anything goes wrong you're the
reason it goes wrong even if it's
defensively even if it's in coaching and
making mistakes on the sidelines somehow
some way because Dak Prescott is the
quarterback of the Cowboys we find a way
to get to him and being real about it as
a player I would feel like that is on
the media at large because the media at
large knows what's the jackpot Cowboys
and when you say Cowboys who are you
talking about Dak Prescott so all
conversations have to lead and end with
Dak Prescott therefore all the
criticisms okay when you did your show
on Fox Sports how often would you have a
rundown meeting and go
we have to get the Cowboys in the
conversation today you're encouraged to
go with the Cowboys on a daily basis I
was just the opposite that's why I'm
here right now because I got tired of ad
nauseum I'm sitting there like why we
keep talking about the Cowboys I mean
this was times when the Cowboys were
500. we got to talk to Cowboys three
times in the first hour I'm like they're
not even that good right now but we
still had to do it because it pays the
bills so I think everyone knows behind
the veil what's driving this like
they're a machine they're a cottage
industry when you talk about the Cowboys
but I'm not gonna lie to you I'm a
former Cowboy I got tired of talking
about them and I think there were deeper
layers there were better teams and there
are more interesting conversations at
times to have but they don't drive the
bottom line like the Cowboys and that
does Marcellus Wiley the former NFL
All-Pro defensive end and his podcast
more to it available uh weekly on The
Dan Patrick Podcast Network you touch on
a topic the Jets quarterback battle with
Zach Wilson and Mike White and then you
say how backups lie about uh loving the
starter explain
yeah I mean what a dynamic and we've all
been through it in the workplace you
know someone who has the job you desire
so how do you coexist with that person
you know do you bring them coffee and
donuts or do you try to spike it are you
sitting there trying to undermine them
it's the same thing in the NFL like when
you're a backup and a capable backup not
a backup who knows I don't have a chance
like I was a backup to Bruce Smith I
didn't have a chance so I didn't have to
go out there and sabotage them but when
I felt like hey I need my reps I need my
opportunities it's time for me to try
and figure out a plan where I can all of
a sudden take over in the Jets situation
this is a perfect dilemma they have two
bad choices you have Zach Wilson with
all this talent and you know that he's
someone you want as your franchise
quarterback but he hasn't lived up to
the billing then you have Mike White who
was compromised in that respect but
everyone believes in him and he has a
great story and we rally around them and
if you're the Jetson organization or
Robert Saleh you're sitting there like I
really have two bad choices but coach is
going to be as faithful as his options
and he doesn't have any other options so
you got to try and rally behind both of
them but when you're a backup to a guy
you know that you're better than or at
least you feel that way boy it's kind of
weird going to work every day going to
practice knowing you're trying to stab
him in the back what's this say about
the position of quarterback quarterbacks
currently in the NFC playoffs Jalen
hurts second round pick Kirk Cousins
fourth round Brock Purdy Mr Irrelevant
Tom Brady's sixth round pick Dak fourth
round pick Taylor Heineken wasn't
drafted and Daniel Jones was the sixth
pick overall
yeah it highlights how important and
tangibles really are and that's
something that gets lost in the process
of becoming a top quarterback uh I hear
a lot of basketball players say this
like the basketball IQ of today's
athlete is low because they're doing so
many specialized trainings so many skill
courses 101s and they don't have the
perspective of the entire game same
thing with the quarterback position they
find them their throwing coach and they
go out there and work on footwork and
all the mechanics but the perspective
and not just on the football field but
like Jalen hurts off the football field
building up that character building up
your leadership skills all those things
are intangibles and they're hard or
impossible to measure therefore people
don't really put focus on them when
you're developing a quarterback but it
comes to light when you get to the
highest level because everybody could
throw everybody could run everybody's
big and strong but who has the will
inside of them and the character to go
even farther how often would you have an
argument
Sports argument
on TV
and it was a real argument like this is
going to stay with us during the
commercial break or after the show
from my perspective I never had that
because I was raised that if we're
really going to argue verbally we're
going to bring out the big guns and I
never brought out the big guns on TV
even though I would shoot here and there
I would try and slice you here and there
I never brought out my big boy why I
heard this in relationship counseling uh
my my counselor told me he said never
argue to win with your wife because then
you're living with a loser and I used to
think the same thing when I used to
debate I was like if I win and try to
destroy this dude now the next segment
and the next show I'm with a loser and
they took it to heart I worked with a
ton of people tremendous tremendous
commentators and broadcasters and very
few of them could just move on they
always took it to heart in part because
they didn't have that character
development of playing the sport I
really believe playing football maybe
understand next play and I can't think
about the last play next conversation I
can't think about the a last
conversation but I would get up there
with some people who would take it into
the break take it offset take it home
and don't want to talk the next day so I
learned early not to go that far with it
maybe that's why I didn't win enough
debates who's the last football player
you'd want to fight
the last football player I want to fight
um
James Harrison is coming to mind we've
had a similar conversation before but I
know he's a big teddy bear so even
though it would hurt in the process I
I'm up for that fight with James
Harrison uh I'm not gonna lie the first
time
that I was able to see
like it would be like a big receiver
really because they are athletic more
athletic than you and ass big so maybe
like a Megatron from the old days or
something like that like a guy who I
know is more athletic to be and as rangy
as me and not that much weaker than me
those would be the guys I don't want to
see would you rather face Justin fields
or Patrick Mahomes
wow where are we uh
Justin Fields uh look I know he has that
wild card factor of the running ability
and every play that breaks down he
smiles because he's like yes this is my
time to shine uh but I want someone like
a Justin Fields because then I can just
bring my Blitz package from the outside
this is something that Bill Belichick
did against Doug Flutie when Doug Flutie
was really making some hay in the in the
league no one could stop him because he
had that running ability and Belichick
said okay let me just keep him in the
pocket let me make him run straight
through the tackles and let's check on
that running ability so there's a way to
slow that down and force him to throw
with Patrick Mahomes no matter what you
do he's still gonna get his numbers he's
still gonna put up points uh the passing
of Franco Harris at the age of 72 coming
up on the 50th Anniversary this weekend
Steelers and the Raiders and maybe the
greatest uh name attached to a play in
sports history
Immaculate Reception rest in peace to
the great
um you know it really hits home
um it's funny when you retire from
football
uh it's really your first death that
you've faced in your life like you just
died in terms of a career in terms of
all of your investment into something
and usually you're in your 20s or 30s
but you have a long life to live and now
you're starting to see for natural
causes those Heroes that you grew up
watching now they're starting to fall
now they're dying and it really hits
home especially when you're a part of
that fraternity or part of the game of
football like we all are
um 72 years young it's just unreal but
what a tremendous Legacy obviously he'll
live on forever through highlights
through his accomplishments but uh it
really hits home for me because I start
to do the mental math and start to say
wow guys that I used to have on my wall
now they're falling great to talk to you
as always Marcellus uh Merry Christmas
to the family and uh we'll talk to you
in the new year all right Merry
Christmas guys take care brother
Marcellus Wiley former NFL All-Pro
defensive end